[Applause]
thank you thank you sir I would like to
present with the text frustration in
decibel on websites so the idea is to
collect metrics from the sessions
reconstruct the session replies and
detect frustration it's relatively easy
but if you think to check millions of
session it's a problem so of course the
answer is to automate these but the
problem is that we have a huge data set
so da the solution was to essentially
reduce an unsupervised problem in a
supervised one trading model invalidated
so essentially we transform the matrix
in features of the model we have two
kinds of matrix so in terms of mouse
movements and clicks so we can obtain a
mouse speed and click-through rate and
so on the next step is to essentially
find good fit
so essentially features that can be
distinguished between frustration or not
for example in case of clicks multiple
clicks consecutive tricks are closed in
space and then we pass to training the
model so essentially once we obtain the
good features we select some journée and
we label and we train the model so at
the end we validate our model so it's a
classification problem so we obtained
this sort of confusion matrix so what
optimized efficiency precision it
depends from the business essentially if
you want to minimize for example the
number of thoughtful false positive so
this is the final pipeline we obtained
so essentially as I said before we
collect the matrix from the session of
every user which we obtain the features
of the model we pass to the model and
then we report to the website the
raishin or not a small fraction of these
sessions are labeled by us and I used to
train and validate the model so
essentially the labeled data is used to
tune the parameters that are they can be
read online by the model in order to
optimize it in terms of precision of
accuracy all this to say that Python
alpide lasts a lot so thank you to all
the contributors of the community and
essentially to represent the 90% of our
staff so it used in the prototyping of
the model for example in the
implementation of the model itself and
of course in all the production deployed
the data pipeline and so on so thank you
[Applause]